Morecambe in its Heyday the super
swimming Stadium the center of a booming
tourist destination fondly remembered by
those who've seen the town's decline
since then it was fabulous it was just a
fabulous fun place to be it was I was
all our second home and anyone who was
born in the 50s will say the same so
that was the Heyday what happened next
um the the buildings were left to rock
and ruin they had weeds growing out of
them nothing nobody was putting any
money into it because they couldn't see
a future but now is a new Heyday on the
horizon this is the site where
morecombe's pool once stood empty for
decades Now 50 million pounds from the
government's leveling up fund to turn it
into this a new Eden project that locals
hope will pull tourists back to the area
the Prime Minister certainly happened to
make a visit promoting a local win
selling a national message
what does leveling up mean because you
hear it a lot
now for me it's something very simple
it's about spreading opportunity and
creating jobs in every single part of
our country
the first time we've heard Rishi sunak's
definition of leveling up the slogans
might sound the same but the reality is
different to what came before
111 projects costing 2.1 billion pounds
money for deprived towns like this one
in the Northwest incredibly welcome for
local residents but this is leveling up
Rishi sunak style done differently to
the way that his predecessor Boris
Johnson would have done and with
different priorities comes different
funding money going to places that might
surprise some
compared to day's funding to the last
round and the change is clear there's
now a smaller share for Yorkshire and
the Midlands more for London the south
west and Southeast
good news for places like folkestone
it's won 20 million pounds for its Town
Center more than many deprived areas
further north local leaders argue the
South needs help too
there is as much deprivation around in
the Southeast as there is anywhere else
in the country especially in the seaside
towns well you organized Sunshine which
brilliant yeah
and we brought the investment Rishi
sunak the first one popularity as the
covid chancellor splashing the cash now
the numbers are smaller and there are as
many losers as there are winners will he
get the payoff he wants Samco to Sky
News Morecambe